you
4203
that's roughly the amount of times I
pitched doing a feature about an early
access skiing game for GameSpot before I
got permission well that game is snow
and yeah I get it
most of you don't really care but come
along with me anyway
it'll be fun lifestyle sports it's hard
to explain why you dedicate huge chunks
of your life for relatively short
reckless moments of pure bliss video
games are brilliant at translating
skating snowboarding motocross BMX and
many other action sports into immensely
enjoyable gaming experiences I spent
countless hours perfecting pipe runs in
1080 snowboarding or kneeling
an insane run on downhill Jam free nor
no one else like that but there's been a
glaring omission of a specific sport in
gaming for all these years
skiing well there was that one game or
my team hero Jonny Moseley enquired
about what if it snowed in San Francisco
what if it snowed in San Francisco and
that shitty Alpine racer arcade game
that I always seemed to sink quarters
into but we need a modern one we need a
better one all right full disclaimer
here I'm a kid from the mountains I'm a
skier through and through and I also
love video game so anything I say here
is just full-on overexcited nonsense and
it's the middle of October right when
skiers in the Northern Hemisphere are
most hungry so it's kind of like a
heroin addict making a video about how
awesome some sweet new shipping of drugs
is and haven't had fix it about buttons
so yeah
hopper most productions a small dev team
in Stockholm first showed snow off
tucked away inside a booth at Gamescom
2013 it was in an early state but it was
immediately apparent that they just got
it the basic bullet points are thus it's
a huge mountain ride with gnarly
features they have real brands they have
animations reference from real skiers
and they have just beautiful looking
grabs and tricks all grounded in reality
yeah the airs and drops are just way
crazier than you'd see in real life but
that's the beauty of video games unlike
SSX where everything is just insane this
game is sincere about real scheme so
they released on early access and yaw
was really rough but it gained enough of
a following for them to expand the team
update regularly and find serious
investment capital they even did an
amazing sound recording session as seen
in his sexy promotional video now a year
and some change later and this game is
well on its way to living up to its
potential a completely overhauled
physics-based skiing system has been
implemented and improved the feel the
speed and turning significantly the
mountain has been overhauled and the
sound really adds to the immersion there
is even a supremely fitting soundtrack
there's a terrain park to plan and even
a halfpipe that will hopefully some day
to be fun to play what is so exciting
about this is that it's a completely
reverent game about free skiing it's
actually playable right now it's nowhere
near perfect and maybe it never will be
but based on the evolution so far I
think they deserve benefit of the doubt
ultimately they want to release as
free-to-play fueled by virtual gear
purchases and eventually add
snowboarding as well they announced it
will be on ps4 and they even have oculus
support which is just ridiculously fun
right now the game is pretty freeform
and the rough edges really do start to
weigh on you the longer you play for
skiers though looking for their fix
before the season starts I'd recommend
this game wholeheartedly ultimately
there is a lot of work ahead of pop the
most and I'm stoked to see what becomes
of it this very well could prove to be
the best skiing game since ski free
you